hi everybody welcome thanks for coming
this is a my talk on Conda press or
reinventing the wheel I work at Quon
site so if you haven't heard of us you
can find us online or you can talk to me
afterwards so just a couple of ground
rules about this talk I have given you a
text color that that this is the minimum
will place the minimum places in the in
the talk that prompts you to say
something you are more than welcome to
talk to interject at any other point in
time and hassle me however you want but
the green is at a minimum okay everyone
understand yes who and Who am I oh I'm
Anthony scope at sits right there so you
can find that yeah sorry in case anyone
was confused okay so that's the ground
rule so please please yeah interject
second part presses a pun you if you
maybe we'll talk about that later on in
the talk but I'm not gonna reveal what
the what the pun is right now okay so
what are we even doing here
so Conda press is a new tool that lets
you take condo packages and turn them
into Python wheels yeah like why why
they so this talk is going to talk about
why in the world you would want to do
such a terrible thing right it sounds
truly truly awful it's gonna demonstrate
that we actually can do such a terrible
thing which is also awful just making
the world a worse place day by day and
then we're gonna dive into like how such
a terrible thing is done and then we're
gonna talk about some like safety
precautions when doing such a terrible
thing right cuz like you know we want
everybody to be safe so
I agree also I forgot to mention one of
the other ground rules there's gonna be
a lot of just excessive animations in
this talk so like yeah used to them
alright so this can't possibly work so
let's go ahead we've made a little
terminal here in our in our space we've
got a temporary directory kind of press
temporary and I'm gonna show you that
this tool actually works so got a lot of
tab a lot of completed commands here but
we're gonna start with time con depress
just let's let's skip out of some of
these things so we're gonna keep right
up here at the top we're gonna just do
don't strip symbols to make it a little
faster and sub der Linux 64 and we're
gonna build a wheel for numpy right now
ah right I need to activate my
environment ha ha ha
okay let's activate the environment and
then we're gonna go ahead and run con
depress and it's gonna run for a little
while and we're will come back to it in
a moment but it it's gonna go ahead and
download download the condo package and
start turning it into a wheel it'll
actually go back up it'll walk the whole
tree the dependency tree and create
wheels for all of the little things in
the dependency tree and so right now you
see live open blas is working it's
grabbing curses and a bunch of other
stuff so this is going to take a moment
we'll talk about why why it also in a
moment harren how's it going hey Mike
well yeah sorry I added animations to
remind myself when to go into shell
alright this is conch by the way so if
you haven't heard of console it's a
different talk but we can also talk
about it here if we want okay so the
postulates one of the postulates of this
talk the first one is that building
software is hard anyone agree or
disagree
yeah there we go thank you thank you all
right the second is that luckily whoops
luckily kind of Forge is a huge
community of about yeah about one and a
half thousand people dedicated to
building software normally in this pie
data stack so unfortunately some people
want to be able to pip install packages
on every freaking platform so what do we
mean by that we mean like Mac Linux
Windows arm PowerPC just everything
right and getting native packages for
that for those those architectures is
actually very difficult so it's and it's
also it's super difficult once you hit a
C extension which I think we can
hopefully all agree upon
but Conda Forge builds on all of those
platforms and so a lot of the hard work
of building pack packages has already
been done so like why would we go and
build wheels from from nothing again if
we already have all the hard work so
what we should just be able to like take
the Conda Forge packages and press them
into a more circular shape
oh yeah okay so what did this do so this
took about a minute to create our numpy
our numpy package so if you look at this
what is it there's a bunch of different
wheels including the whole stack right
includes your C runtimes it includes
includes Python itself it includes TK +
Z Lib and all this other junk and Wow
that's just a lot and and kind of crazy
and so sorry I skipped to that a little
early but let's so let's go back to what
the vision of Conda press is okay so to
orient ourselves a bit alright so first
things first package XYZ is released or
a package version XYZ is released
Conda Forge goes out and builds that
version right like this is just
something that happens Conda Forge in
our vision statement Conda Forge will
then also go out and build the wheel for
you
and then after the wheel is built it
will publish that wheel back to pi pi
and then finally everything is awesome
awesome and we can go home and and rest
on our laurels right so then we would
have wheels for all these different
architectures and everything so what did
that command do or sorry I'm not
supposed to say that you guys can
embellish you know you can say something
else too this is just a prompt for you
so it created all these wheels and we
can if you didn't know this already
wheels are just zip files so you can go
in here and so let's make another little
temporary directory and unzip one of
these wheels so like let's unzip the
numpy wheel and see OOP sorry yeah it
should be yeah yeah we needed to do dot
dot numpy blah blah okay so well bam it
and it did a bunch of stuff so this is
what the contents of the numpy will
actually look like there's the dist info
directory which which contains a bunch
of stuff like the metadata so if we go
and look in you know numpy - 1.7 dot 3
dot just info metadata we can see this
contains what the you know what the
requirements for the numpy package are
it lists these other requirements these
are just taken from the Conda package it
lists you know all the other at the
license and a bunch of other stuff and
and you can go in there and and you know
mess around with other things
note that this there's a bin directory
and then there's which kind of mirrors
the UNIX file like structure the file
file structure there's also the numpy
module directory so if you LS numpy here
you'd see what you would be able to
import from from numpy and yeah so like
if you wanted to install this wheel you
would need to build out all of those
other little dependent or you need to
install all of those dependent
wheels and as we saw this contained like
a lot of really really weird stuff like
a wheel for Python right so that's not
great right that kind of is sucks so oh
yeah oops there's my extra shell so
right clearly Conda press is doing too
much work in this case right we we went
out we tried to build a wheel we got way
more than we bargained for and that's
that's not good so it would be great if
we could skip building on building
Python and building like all of the
other Python dependencies right because
presumably those are also pip
installable or we could build wheels for
those things independently and like we
have these things showing up in metadata
that we like you can't possibly or we we
ought not go and put on pipe I like
maybe there shouldn't be like a C
runtime on pipe I like just I'm just
throw that out there maybe there should
be but like it's kind of weird to have
it there and have pip manage that so
because that's not really what pips goal
is necessarily so you know kinda press
is here to protect you well shoot I'd
missed it
okay well that's let's go back so let's
go up one directory and do RM dash R
star cuz we're living on the edge and
let's do let's add so here was our
previous command and let's just add
another command line option called skip
Python that will hopefully help us skip
all of the Python stuff and you know
we'll sit here and watch this because
it's kind of cool so this right now it's
building the the wheel for the runtime
because python like this is independent
MP links to the runtime independently of
linking it through pipe through through
Python itself we if we scroll up here
if I can scroll up you see we're
skipping things like read line and TK so
we're skipping these dependencies of
Python which is nice
we're still building open Blas because
you know numpy depends on open Blas and
we're skipping Python itself and bam
that only took 30 seconds to build a
numpy wheel from the existing Conda for
packages which is like a huge win and in
a lot of cases now like you can see like
oh it still depends on like Lib G
Fortran and and Lib GCC and and Bluffs
but like this is a much smaller more
more manageable set of of packages so
well like does this actually work right
like that's the that's the big question
so let's go over to another terminal and
we'll just say because we're really
living on the edge here we'll say a
virtual M C PE test so we're gonna make
a virtual environment to to test this in
and stop me if you have any questions
and now because we're really really bold
we're gonna start up bash okay sorry
little inside joke but we're starting to
bash and we're going to not have
tab-completion anymore which sucks and
source have been activate is that right
such like yeah yeah yeah activate right
no such file or directory
OCP test that's right I changed it in my
notes cool alright so now we're in this
new virtual environment you know we can
say like which Python and it's the right
Python and we can do pip install what is
it home slash CP temp and star dot wheel
so we're just gonna grab all of the
wheels we just created in our last
command
it's going to install them oh no it's
alright it was already satisfied so
that's not good so let's exit out a
Bosch and let's do this again CP test
let's make a new virtual invite yeah
make a new virtual environment
- and then source activate it's gonna be
the right Python and we'll pip install
these wheels it's gonna go through and
install them well and that's like
definitely the first battle in any in
any in in any version of like said
another new virtual environment let's go
ahead and start up Python and we will
import numpy as NP because we're not
animals and you know do NP a range or
something in a range of six because
that's a good number
alright our thirty second wheel for
numpy actually worked and is installable
in a complete like new environment so
that that is uh that's that so ok let's
go back to the other terminal and say
make a little temporary directory again
and moving on for the next part of my
notes which are definitely missing cool
but I think I knew what I wanted to do
which was just unzip the numpy piece
again and just sort of show you that
it's it hasn't really changed it's still
basically the same thing you know we got
rid of some of the dependencies that
because we're not really depending on
Python anymore so those got filtered out
and that made this installable again as
well any questions
criticisms yeah
can I show you that blasts actually
works that's a great question so what
should I do for a bla so it's a good at
Blas example yeah so it works anyway so
that what that show well it's a function
fancy is this what you wanted to see
does this prove it to you or should we
actually run some some linear algebra
code I don't have to do that I don't
have to do linear algebra on stage yeah
that's true that's kind of that's cool
yeah it does say mkl Wow interesting
we're learning so much here listen it's
zeroed at 0.6 I'm not claiming it's
perfect I'm claiming that it works okay
so what is oh yeah yeah that's true
that's true that's true so like but we
need to do it in the in in the virtual
environment space so like CD or like ldd
sorry
let's get out of bash because that's
frustrating
[Music]
CPE tests and then what is it it's like
Lib Python 37 site packages God you just
gotta love Python packaging or slash
core you just you really gotta love and
just really gotta love all of this stuff
right like it's amazing so where is it
what is it it's linking to see Blas
right here yeah yeah it is in it's
linking to the one in in the virtual
environment so voila that that was done
correctly Thank You Matty and Ralph and
Francesca for a light helping me through
this okay let's go back to the the
slides I guess that's the next step whoa
I would say the last one is ellipsis but
I don't know all right so let's go
through some terrible terminology I
didn't make this up so I'm not gonna own
it I'm gonna blame other people but we
have built skinny wheels so far okay
that's what they're called unfortunately
each skinny wheel basically only
contains the package that it purports to
that is that name so like if you have
numpy it only contains numpy so you can
if you want to think of these this is
kind of like a road bike it can go fast
in ideal conditions it's small it's lean
there are fat wheels which are what most
people what these include all of the
dependencies that can't easily be found
elsewhere now that's a very nebulous
concept that we've tried to formalize in
Khanda press with some of these options
like skip Python for examples the
libraries the shared libraries of their
dependencies that aren't found in other
Python packages because you know like
you know that I guess so like in analogy
to a cruiser a fat wheel will get you
there without a lot of extra gears so
they're gonna be bigger but you know
they might be slower to install it
cetera so you know we are don't worry we
are here to protect you from
terrible secret of wheels and back to
the terminal I guess okay so let's go
back down one and armed us our star
because you know that's how we roll and
Conda press has another tool that we can
use to take many wheels and turn them
into one wheel so we use this merge tool
and this is a general tool so you could
go grab wheels off of pi PI right now
and merge them together if you like
you know I don't know had nothing better
to do I guess and then we're just gonna
say output as the existing wheel and
we'll go ahead and whoops oh I I remove
them all that's cool yeah cuz I just did
the RM - our start because we were
living on the edge nice cool let's let's
just make them again it only took a few
seconds right so not a big deal and then
we'll go back to our merge version I
probably just have skipped it but
basically merge all it does is it is it
looks at all the metadata figures out
which one should be the top one this or
the one that you want it to be named by
because we also have this property of a
top level and then this will just go
ahead and combine all the files together
in kind of a dumb way so if there's like
multiple files with the same name
they'll just overwrite each other
hopefully they have the same hash value
which is would be good so okay so let's
do the the merge utility so again this
just reads in all of the wheels and then
starts writing out these files it
actually is takes an annoying amount of
time for what it's doing but it does in
in effect work and we'll see this in a
moment so
yeah this is iterations per second this
just uses this library called TQ DM it's
pretty great yeah Marius turned me on to
it so like you literally just wrap it
around any like antecedent of any for
loop and you get that bar yeah cool so
like we still have the other wheels
around but if we see D into T again oops
I'm Kader T and then we see the end of
that and then we unzip the wheel again
you'll see like now the wheel has
blossom it and all this other junk and
it still just retains the numpy it still
only retains like the numpy metadata and
if we go and look at the requirements of
the numpy metadata it's basically
nothing because everything is contained
in this wheel cool yeah you thought I
was just showing you metadata for
nothing no this was a learning
opportunity you have taken and if you
look in Lib you know you can see all of
the other things that were in that wheel
so this is a fully redistributable
single wheel that has all of numpy we
could have done this from the start
because you know why I have to do two
commands and you can do one so if we did
like time and then in the normal Conda
press if we had just passed in Faton to
this it would create a fat wheel so it
would basically do the merge immediately
after not a big deal merge is just an
extra extra tool so hmm let's go back
okay so how does all this work I did say
that I would tell you how it all worked
in the in the abstract there's basically
only four files in Conda press it's
written in conch as you can see by the
xsh things and there's really only two
classes of any note in in this there is
something that represents Conda
artifacts which is the artifact info
package or artifact in intro info class
and so that is a read-only version of
representation of Conda pack
and then there is a wheel class that
lives in the wheel file because you know
names and that's a read/write version of
of wheels so you can read in a wheel and
write it back out or read in multiple
wheels put them in a list write them
back out and it's not very big
excessive animation inserted not huge
there we go right so it's it's less than
two thousand lines of code it's maniacal
and evil probably but there it is
thank you all right so there are some
disclosures to make about the current
state of the world and in terms of
especially in terms of that wheel so you
can overwrite files I mentioned that
already so if both numpy and Sai PI
contain open blas then both open bosses
will be written to disk right so because
we're mirroring a UNIX filesystem okay
this is actually a pretty common case
straight because we saw that run times
are showing up anytime we linked in a C
library and then yes yeah that's gross I
I agree it's gross but in fact it's
actually kind of the way that wheels and
pip work right now so it's not
considerably grosser than the others in
the state of the world and if you build
on the same infrastructure all of those
wheel all of those files shared objects
that you're you're overwriting they're
all ABI compatible with one another so
that's the big difficulty here it's like
how do you make sure that things are ABI
and API compatible and if you're doing
it all from the same compatibility layer
then it all just works and if you're not
that's sucks and I'm sorry
and that's probably a problem for users
but you know at least you have a wheel
right now and Conda Forge does a ton of
work on making sure things are ABI
compatible so look don't under this
don't underestimate that
another disclosure is that there are
namespace differences
so the names for packages on pie-pie are
not the same as names for packages on
con forge so that is problematic and
there probably needs to be a big old
global mapping between these two things
so that you can resolve them in fact
this mapping actually exists in but not
in a collated way so like all the Conda
Forge feedstocks that come from pipe I
have this information you just need a
tool to go and enroll through them and
build that mapping for you it possibly
with some you know user like human
annotation yeah that's just got to
happen prefix substitution issues this
is another fascinating part of this I in
my opinion Gill I'm so glad you brought
that point up yeah I'm just thrilled
that you brought that point up so Conda
press actually does a degree of
redirection for us already in particular
like let's look at F 2 pi does anyone
not know what FTP is all right so no
shame
it lives in numpy it's a binary it
translates for a trend of Python cool
we're good Fortran 77 I believe not not
90 so in the numpy that wheel that we
created there's a bin at /f 2pi that's
the original script that comes in the
condo package but condo press writes a
numpy - 1 dot 7.3 data scripts F 2 pi
and pip will go in and replace the one
in scripts or the one from bin with the
one in scripts ok so it replaces the
second one with the first one because
like that's how wheels work apparently
alright time for a shell so yeah so like
now if we do so let's just look at what
these are that's the whole point of
here so if we look at f 2 pi just oh
sorry i should be in t do it oh shoot
sorry CDT and then unzip this thing
again
and if we do less bin F 2 pi see it's
got this like pretty crazy initial
statement for like how to execute and it
basically is just importing numpy and
then executing it that's kind of and
it's got all this stuff from the
Anaconda distribution that we don't
actually care about anymore or like a
prefix reference this gets replaced with
the one that's in numpy oh sorry it's
data scripts F to PI and so Conda press
is writing this terrible piece of bash
which does a redirection into the low
the current environment right so it's
it's going and looking up for the the
source name of the file stripping out a
couple of things finding where the real
F to PI lives in in in our local
environment and then exacting that file
from instead alright
using the process substitution so we
already do actually a bunch of like
prefix resolution dynamically at runtime
in Conda press because that's the only
way it can work because wheels are
static cool we're good we're onboard and
we could extend this to do like other
runtime wrappers for prefix redirection
if we needed to an environment setting
including like just screw it like inject
code into a knit top high and like
you're good to go right like that's all
you need like that would work and it
would solve a lot of problems here we
have a dynamic language we can we can
get around any of these prefix sub
stitute issues it's just a matter of
knowing what they are alright alright
well what do you guys want what what
package should I try to make a wheel out
of right now
I am SIA hi MC yeah yeah yeah right I
think my MT was the first one let's just
try it
it'll probably fail and that'll be great
so let's do let's just go up here so
here's how I would do it because I want
to be very specific so I would say I
would actually go to whoops let's just
create a come-on control new whatever
anaconda org so I would go here and I
would say I would search PI MC and see
what like the most recent 3/7 version is
what yeah oh nice oh it's a no arch
package come on that's that's easy
is there another one rust do we have a
rust package we do have a rust package
all right so like yeah let's just let's
just do this and I would say maybe we'll
get back to PI MC a moment cuz no arch
packages are really just a copy from so
that's a that I don't even know what
rust depends on probably probably not a
lot but you know we can do this multiple
times let's just have fun right
how much time do I have ten minutes
we're eight minutes feel free to ask
questions and things to you like kind of
question time
yeah yeah I mean I like I feel that yes
so so the reason you can't pip install
Kondo press yet is actually I want that
vision statement that we got back to you
to be complete so I want Conda press to
be the alpha tester for getting wheels
built on Conda Forge and then pushed up
to pi PI at that point Conda press will
be PIP installable
all right all right and it looks like
we've built a rust package more or less
I do
Wow I have a rusty wheel I I rolled into
that one okay let's let's go back and do
and do this is actually a good use case
so PI MC free OOP where was it
hi I'm c3 or is it just PI MC when you
that's PI MC 3 wait so what's the PI MC
package yeah real package just put their
major version in their name that's why
I've never done anything real like I
can't even copy from the browser without
opening up key
I cannot hear the snark so oh yeah kinda
activate CP and uh okay let's go check
and on rust
I guess it's it's actually writing the
merged wheel now so yeah you can do
esoteric stupid things like this were
you okay right there perfect we we
created a PI MC wheel you can see it
because we skipped Python like it's
skipping a lot of lot of stuff like it's
skipping pandas and skipping H 5 PI it's
skipping all the stuff that it knows
that it can get from other places or
that in theory should have other Python
wheels available or other Python
packages available rest has been
Cynthiana we're not getting into a no no
sorry that that's the PI MC browsers or
terminal yeah rust doesn't depend on
Theon oh that would be fascinating Wow
good good good one Madi
so if why don't we will go and look at
this right as M caterer T hmm why can't
they make Wow
you know I expected a lot of errors but
not that one
nice cool should I just like delete my
con yeah I think Gil is suggesting what
what what is it iron CD dot dot and
you're right it's wrong it's wrong it's
wrong it's that all right all right I
think we're having fun now finally
serious question oh no okay so these
wheels are being trained against the
Conda forge ABI surfaces right yeah
pre-install hai pyaar hai wheels okay so
the question is will are this is being
visit these are being made from condo
for the condo for jbi are this
compatible of other things on pi p i
great question
there's sort of two answers to that
so one this can take any channel so it's
not just kind of forage or defaults you
can pass in any channel I didn't show
that off whatever the second thing is
that condo forge at least builds against
a very like old ABI and if you're if
you're running on many Linux many most
many Linux one packages and and this and
Conda and Conda Forge are compatible
ABI wise or they should be there they
might not be in all cases I'm not going
to guarantee that per se the other thing
to note is that like this works on more
than just like the menu in expect right
Conda press our test suite runs on winix
Linux Mac and Windows you can build
wheels for all of those systems you
could build wheels for arm and PowerPC
if you wanted to using this because
that's what con depressed or kind of
Forge builds packages for the for those
architectures so this is an entry way to
building wheels for all platforms of the
same command that that's like the real
power yes many nothing platform specific
and Conda press itself except for the
fact that like pip wheels on Windows get
installed in a weird way and like
Windows has some slight differences
so can I a great segue to my last slide
so I want to thank
marchello I also want to call out like
please send help for this project it
definitely needs work right now you need
to answer your question we need to be on
the same platform so there's a couple of
caveats mostly the our path rewriting is
we're not doing that in a platform
independent way so there are tools like
there are tools like leaf that allow you
to do dynamic library our path rewriting
on other platforms than the so like you
could rewrite on Linux a dll or on
Windows you could rewrite in SOS our
path I've never used that ABI Condit
does so and they use it all the time but
like I'm too lazy to figure that out so
someone else can and that would be a
great great place to send help the other
big issue is that for some wacky reason
even though these things are just zip
files pip does not respect unzipping
symlinks and so every to get around this
we have to do a hard copy of every sim
linked file in our wheel it's totally
stupid there's an issue opened about it
if someone could please fix that that
would be amazing yeah yeah five minutes
or even I thought I was out of time but
that's great so we could dramatically
decreased wheel size file size we need a
little bit of help integrating this into
Khanda smithy Marcello's doing some of
that work but I'm sure he would love
help we need help integrating the
warehouse I know that there is a github
action to do this now to push to the
warehouse but like again still need help
there and I think that is it so thank
you very much everybody